Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
Yes,
I am.
How are you?
What's going on?
How is your week going?
You realize it's July,
man.
The summer is just,
it's just with Gig away.
Do you know what fucking rained out here yesterday in July?
It's unbelievable.
It never rains out here.
It never rains in California.
But boy don't they warn you
it pours man.
It pulls.
It just,
it just was this thunder and,
and there was rain and it just poured down and I was like,
Gee,
willikers you know,
I had a couple of shirts dry and out on the fucking porch there because,
uh,
you know,
you can do that out here because it never rains in February and that is it.
There's a little bit of June gloom and you're like,
Ooh,
is it no precipitation,
blue balls?
That's all it is.
And yesterday just was an absolute downpour.
And uh,
like 20 minutes later was over and everything was dried up and you would never
know what happened.
You know,
like a perfect robbery,
like a robbery gone.
Right.
Nobody gets hurt.
We get in,
we get up,
we get the jewels.
Okay.
Blonde.
Um,
yeah.
Franco goes in with the others have been,
sorry,
I just combined three different movies,
two different movies,
something like that.
I have no fucking idea.
All I know is a,
this is one of these days.
I forgot it was Thursday and I forgot I had to do a podcast and I have some
shit.
Ted Do
some shit to do.
All right.
I am,
uh,
going down to comic con today.
Can you believe that
Belper hater of all marvel and DC fucking movies?
I don't hate him.
I just stay.
I,
they do absolutely nothing for me.
You know,
I like the hulk.
I'm an angry fuck.
Or I can relate to him,
right?
I've inhaled a cigar.
I've turned green before.
You know,
I can't jump like that.
A kid.
I can't not crush cars the way he does,
but I get it.
I like the hulk.
I liked the way he talks to,
you know how fucking stupid,
he basically talks like Tarzan,
which really made no sense if he was raised by wolves or whatever the fuck was
going on there.
How the fuck he learned how to speak English.
You know what I mean?
I can't tell if he was unbelievably compromised in that relationship with Jane
or if it was a brilliant fucking thing cause he could just,
you didn't understand what she was saying.
You know,
how long into that relationship do you think before he looked at that little
chimpanzee and just fucking rolled his eyes?
Like you fucking believe this shit.
Okay,
it's this,
this,
this woman would be dead out here without me at an edge and all she's doing is
bitch moaning and complaining.
All right,
well live at in nature.
We're perfectly safe.
Okay.
I'm providing,
we don't have to pay any taxes.
This is like not the way W we're in fucking in right now.
And they go,
Jay.
Yeah,
go,
go take a bite on the apple.
You know,
that is one thing that I have learned.
Okay.
As a 50 year old man.
I'll tell you right now guys,
if you're out with the ladies,
okay.
Save Your fucking money.
Okay.
Do not spend money on women.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do it cause you want to,
but don't do it because you think it's going to make them happy.
It will in the moment.
But I swear to God I don't give a fuck.
You could literally buy a woman the fucking space shuttle.
All right.
And put our initials on the side of it.
Okay.
And take her,
I,
I don't know where the fuck you do with the space shuttle.
All right.
Whatever they take her to and from work.
I don't like sitting like this.
My hair is like hanging down.
Well we can't take off Corazon holy honey,
whenever I just get me to work,
I swear to God you don't,
you'd literally be in the Doghouse within fucking 24 hours of doing that one
stupid comment.
MMM.
I was actually joking with a buddy of mine the other day.
I was saying like,
you know,
sentiment,
if patching shit up with your wife was deductible,
I wouldn't pay taxes for the past three years.
That's all I'm ever doing.
You know,
I feel like the boss's son who just keeps fucking up,
but for some reason he doesn't get fired.
Do you know what I mean?
It's after like the 50th time you've done something wrong that we could just
like,
I,
I really don't understand how,
how did I,
how did I end up in this position?
Um,
but that's neither here nor there.
Okay.
If you want to make up with your wife,
take her out for ice cream.
Okay.
I'm telling you it's,
it's romantic.
It gives him a sugar rush.
All right.
They feel like they're in some Tom Hanks movie and it really doesn't cost that
much money.
You know,
if you could just keep your cool while you fucking stand in line at the artisan
ice cream place that they want to go to before you go up there and you order a
mint chocolate chip and they tell you it's not in season.
Well if that happened to me in San Francisco and have that story,
it's not in season,
then I'm going to cross the street to the drug store and it came back with a
pint of it.
You know,
I should've walked into their fucking ice cream place.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
I try.
Here's the deal.
If you,
if you want to get adventurous with ice cream,
follow people under 40.
All right.
Do you just want the old school simple shit?
You follow old people because eventually they'd go into the pharmacy,
right?
And that's where they have chocolate,
vanilla,
strawberry
patchwork,
chocolate chip.
How many flavors were there?
There was mint chocolate chip that was peppermint.
That was like,
that was fancy back then.
Not now.
It's like,
I don't even know what the fuck it is.
They got candy bars in there.
They got like a,
they have sugar and salt with a shot of espresso and some sort of social justice
warrior thing written in fucking a whip cream.
You know,
I followed Joe Rogan is most of the free world does,
um,
on Instagram.
And I saw this whole thing about the okay sign.
How funny is that?
According to Joe Rogan,
the okay sign
these people is a joke.
Tried to say that you can,
you can find white power in there like this,
which I don't know.
I see three fingers in is in a zero.
I see zero to three.
I see 30.
I see.
Uh,
uh,
I dunno,
it could make it shadow puppets may be a rooster.
I don't see where the white powers in there,
but they tried to say that.
You could see in there,
I guess the p would be your forearm up into the circle and then the,
the three fingers will be the w,
Oh fuck,
I'm smart.
Or does that mean I'm racist,
racist,
racist.
So my names,
they started it as a joke and then dopes believed it.
And then actual,
even bigger dopes.
White supremacists started using it and now it's actually going to get bad,
you know,
which is so fucking stupid.
Like why would you ban that?
You know what I mean?
That's like banning,
you know,
let's say it was actually race.
Would you ban somebody?
Go and see Heil.
Why would you ban that?
Let people do it that then,
then you know who the Nazis are,
right?
If you don't let people do it,
then you're like,
all right,
is this guy a Nazi or does he know Jujitsu or was he just a fan of Telus?
Telly Savalas oh no,
wait a minute.
That's all freckles.
Hey showed up to tell some shit jokes,
right?
And then all of a sudden,
all the lines get blurred.
Okay,
you got to let Connie people have their signs.
You know,
how are you doing Seth?
I'm all carry.
You gotta let them do that.
And then you got to let morons,
you know,
fucking do this.
SIEG Heil and I,
Hitler's birthday on April 20th all right,
well the hippies of behind him smoking marijuana.
Hey Man,
like
Nazis,
the mellow man,
right?
You got to have all those people,
I think.
I mean,
you'd like to have not have others,
but I,
I really don't think how like banning sides.
I've always thought that was,
that was like,
I guess wishful thinking
in my world.
If you ban racial gestures than people aren't racist anymore.
You don't need to fix what's between their ears.
You just need to fix just sticky.
Elations when we come back,
Dr Phil will cure a heroin addict within two commercial breaks.
Uh,
you ne to stop doing heroin and you need to put on some weight.
You're right,
Dr Phil,
let me shake your hand and subtly steal your wash so I can cop right behind your
fucking soundstage.
Did I say cop?
Yes,
I did.
That's how old I am.
Uh,
you know what's great about being a parent besides everything is all the fun
fucking signs he gets stuck in your head.
You know,
as I'm talking to you guys about Neo Nazis in my head,
I'm singing pop,
pop,
pop puppy dog pals,
poke poke,
poke.
But no,
no,
no bro,
Bro.
Bro,
bro,
Bro.
About pop,
pop,
you know,
most awesome is my daughter sings along to it now.
She just goes pop,
pop,
pop.
And then anytime they,
they,
she just goes dog.
It's funny to parents.
Um,
yeah,
she's amazing.
Um,
I,
I get now why people have like eight kids.
I get it.
It's fucking amazing.
I mean,
if he can just get past me and tired and then eventually hating you between the
ages of about 11 and a,
I don't know,
depending on how much you actually did do wrong,
it might be the rest of your life,
but usually I think it lasts somewhere.
A mid college
I would think.
I don't know.
I've already thought about how I'm going to handle her teenage years.
I'm just going to listen.
I know,
I know.
I'm cramping your style,
man.
But can you just go to lunch with your old man?
I swear to God.
Here's the deal.
I like,
I'll let you walk in first.
You know,
just in case some of your friends are in there.
All right.
And then if none of your friends are in there,
then I'll come in like the fucking elephant man.
And you all sit down and just have lunch with me.
And if any of friends show up,
you know?
Okay.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know what to do at that point.
I guess I would walk out,
you know,
how amazing is that?
Like a,
as this little perfect being that needs you on such a ridiculous level,
it almost makes you cry within like 10 years.
Like treats you like the fucking plague.
You know,
I'm kind of excited for it,
for the whole fucking journey because at the end of the day,
I am a loner,
so I think I'll be able to sub.
No,
I won't.
What'd your own flesh and blood turns their back on you.
Um,
all right.
I think we need to do some advertising here.
Donut at some point.
None of them only 12 minutes in normally 12 minutes.
And you know what I did?
I tell you guys that I watched the a moto GP from Germany or seek,
um,
from Germany and I saw a
fucking Mark Marquez fucking rundown
Jorge Low Lorenzo.
Now I,
I just don't understand the whole fucking tire thing.
These fucking guys,
whenever they use the soft tire,
they're always leading in the beginning and then eventually the soft tires to
fucking soft.
It starts to wear down and then they're fucked,
you know?
I mean,
at this point,
the way mark mark has his winning.
Why don't you just go,
well,
what is mark going to use today to give ourselves a fighting chance?
Because as far as I know,
Jorge,
Lorenzo,
he fucking,
uh,
you won a championship three years ago.
Right?
Marquez is one for the last five.
Let me look this up.
Moto g p
Jambi almost.
Am I on the right Internet?
Okay,
here we go.
Oh God.
They just let me know who.
Okay.
How about Valentino Rossi?
Huh?
Always making the podium.
That's a weird thing in racing that I,
I don't get how you get too old to do it.
I mean,
as long as you're fucking,
especially race car drive,
as long as your foot works,
can you press down on the gas?
I mean,
the engine has to go 200 miles an hour.
You don't,
right.
I mean,
you just kind of ride along.
All right.
But I guess your reflexes,
your reflex is get,
uh,
Oren is good.
And then,
um,
I dunno,
you just stopped winning.
It's crazy.
All right.
So basically,
first of all,
shout out to Spain because since 2010 a Spaniard is one at every year except
2011 when arguably the greatest motorcycle name of all time.
Casey stoner.
One more time.
Casey stoner,
one in 2011.
All right,
Mark Marquez one it until 2017 2016 Jorge rental one in 2015 and then 2014 2013
was mark.
Mark is Jorge.
You Lorenzo was 2012 Casey stoner,
please report to the principal's office.
2011 and 2010 was Jorge Low Renzo.
And then the previous decade was the Valentino Rossi show where that genius won
it seven times in nine years.
Honorable Mention to Casey and 2007 and also the last American,
the last Yank to win at 2006,
Nikki.
Hey,
and what's going on?
Do you still ride the fucking motorcycles kit?
Dody was crazy.
He's doing fucking wheelies in the seventh grade and we also want in 2000 with
Kenny Roberts Jr
um,
Valentino Rossi won in 2001,
2002,
2003 2004,
2005,
2008 and 2009 and he was riding Honda's in the beginning
2001,
two and three.
And then the unthinkable,
he switched to Yamaha and everybody thought it was an inferior product.
And not only did he fucking win with them,
he won four times with Yamaha.
Yamaha.
There you go.
There's some quick motorcycle history.
I don't know shit about it,
but somebody who watches a shit,
please explain to me why you would ever run a race.
Right?
Or race on the fucking soft tire.
The super soft or whatever.
They always seem to blister or just they,
they shit the bed,
right when it counts.
It's like you lead the whole fucking race,
you know,
and then all of a sudden with like 15 to 12 laps left,
all of a sudden somebody with a medium tires,
something like that just runs you down.
You know,
like the soft tire is sort of the,
uh,
the heartthrob of the tire industry.
You know what I mean?
Well,
if you're basing your whole life on your looks,
I mean you're,
you,
you know,
you're going to have,
your career's going to be prompt probably shorter than a professional athletes
cause you're going to get old and somebody else younger is going to come along.
But the medium,
I think the medium tires,
the way to go,
it seems to be the way it go.
Way to go.
I have no fucking idea,
but all I know is a,
I have to figure out a way next year in April to get to that Goddamn Moto GP
race.
But anyways,
I didn't mention a,
why are you going to comic con bill,
why are you going to any apolis bill?
I'm going down the first one.
I'm flying a helicopter down.
Uh,
it's the first time I've flown since May top,
I remember how to do this shit.
Now I'm flying with an instructor.
Everybody relax.
So I'm flying down there and I am,
uh,
is moderating,
hosting.
Um,
I'm sitting down for an hour in front of a crowd of 6,000 people
and I am hosting,
uh,
what do you call it?
The uh,
okay.
The cast of better call Saul.
I'm getting to interview all of those people and I'm going to see Vince Gilligan
for the first time in a long time,
which is going to be great.
I'm going to thank him for giving me an acting career.
And,
uh,
and then afterwards,
some of the casts of breaking bad's going to come out and then we're going to do
an hour with them.
And um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I don't know why I,
this is one of these gigs where I was like,
yeah,
I'd love to do that.
And then the second I,
you know,
the day comes and I'm like,
wait,
what am I out of my fucking,
what the fuck am I going to say?
But I,
I know that everybody's got great stories,
so all I gotta do is just,
I just got to set people up.
I did this recently on another show
that escapes me.
I have no fucking idea what I am.
I short term memories for Shit.
I have no idea.
But anyways,
it's going to fly down to San Diego.
I'm going to a host both of those things.
Then I get to watch the premiere of better call Saul.
You know what's better than that?
Then I come back,
you know,
better call Saul was one of my favorite actors on television right now.
Joe To
Rosa Smoking,
Joe de Rosa.
Oh,
by the way,
you know,
very strong rumors,
very strong rumors that Belper and showed Rosa are back together in talks about
getting uninformed going again,
very strong rumors.
Remember when guns and roses was getting back together and everybody is going to
happen.
Is it going to happen?
You know,
but guess what?
Yeah,
I'm sitting down with all fucking Joe to Rosa next week
to see if I can figure out a way to get to,
to fit myself into his incredible busy schedule as an actor,
yet to be nominated for an Emmy.
But we all know it's inevitable.
I sound like a breaking his balls,
but I think he's fucking great on that show.
And,
uh,
I can't wait for this season and,
um,
it is a beyond and honor that Vince asked me to do this.
So I just hope I don't fuck it up to be honest with you.
You know?
Um,
and I also don't know how,
how do I get into this?
I mean,
can I,
can I talk about like how last season ended without getting stampeded by 6,000
nerds going see spoiler in lyric Meehan.
All right,
everybody.
Okay,
here we go.
I got a little bit of a,
some advertising re here.
Um,
hey nia,
is the oatmeal almost ready?
Ah,
Shit.
All right,
I gotta get in there.
Alright.
Butcher box,
butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage bread,
pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box means start with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones before you kill them.
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a fat fuck,
which probably you'll go through that in three days.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef,
pork,
mixed
box,
custom box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
Oh Man.
That's when you're throwing down at the grill.
That's when your eyes light up like a kid in the candy store.
I get to pick my own guts.
Antibiotic slash hormone free.
No,
we're not talking about bill burr.
We're talking about butcher box,
but your box believes in a healthier food system where everyone has access to
meets the way nature intended,
the way you used to be able to do it.
When you went hunting with the musket,
the only foreign object in that thing was the little pellet that you shut into
its brain.
Nature intended free of antibiotics and hormones that you mainly raised on an
open pasture before they kill them.
Butcher,
Buck selection,
butcher box.
Carefully cure rates to find a selection and cuts and it makes it a breeze to
customize your own delivery.
Build your own box to get exactly what you and your family love.
By the way,
we're talking about butcher box,
not a robot.
You can have sex with you.
Weirdo nerds.
Choose your delivery frequency with the custom customizable subscription recipes
are available on butcher box websites and videos are available to follow along
on butcher box youtube channel.
I'm going to tell you something right now that heritage,
I cannot say enough about the heritage pork
heritage,
bread,
pork.
It's the best pork chop I've ever made at home.
Delicious my mouth waters when I read this,
when I read this article.
All right,
to receive free making from life.
To think that while I was just on the Jim Jeffrey show and he had the nerve to
say that America is not number one
when you can actually live in this country,
choose your own cuts of beef and win Free Bacon for life plus $10 off your
order.
Go to butcher box.com click on the big bacon banner on the homepage and use the
per you u are at checkout.
Go now.
Limited time offer.
Please let Jim Jefferies know that he is in the best country in the world
because you can win free bacon for life.
Um,
I did a show on a Tuesday and I have such a great time with him.
It's like a,
you know,
he said this thing about me said,
he goes,
some people,
people ask me about bill burr.
I say he's going to make a great 80 year old.
But the great thing about Jim is he's a bit of a curmudgeon too,
you know,
so we have to fucking curmudgeons from different hemispheres,
the northern and southern hemisphere and together we form a global force of
grumpiness.
Um,
I should actually post the link to,
uh,
to that interview.
I had a great time on the show and,
and uh,
I would like to do it more often.
They are,
I set it Postmates as usual,
your stomach and the rest of your life are at war.
You need to eat,
but you can't stop what you're doing to deal with it.
And the only fast things that deliver are not what you want.
Introducing Postmates,
the APP that adds a delivery.
Option two,
your favorite restaurants.
Imagine anything you want to eat delivered.
You don't have to drive,
park,
or even talk to a f to the phone.
Talk on the phone to order Jesus Christ.
Just download the APP in order 24 hours a day,
365 days,
days a year.
You don't have to interact with anybody.
You can be completely naked doing this just to make sure you throw in a row
before the,
uh,
the fucking guy gets there.
Old Lady or person transgender.
I don't know what I'm supposed to say these days.
Postmates will bring you what you want within the hour.
You can even see where your food is and track your driver.
Can we watch them to make sure he's not eating some of your fries?
You forget to get eggs and milk.
No problem.
Craving a tasty burger.
Check looking for the perfect bottle of red wine or summer bare.
Order up.
Oh,
that sounds delicious.
19 days into sobriety of fucking summer Ale.
Postmates is,
I only got 11 more days of this shit.
12 more days.
Then I'm back on an August.
Postmates is your new longterm munchies booty call for unlimited time.
Postmates is giving you $100 of free delivery credit for your first seven days
to start your free deliveries.
Download the APP today and use your coat borough 100 that's code for 100 for a
hundred dollars of free delivery credit for your first seven days.
Save the hassle,
man.
Get the food you love at Postmates with code burr 100 I like that.
I might steal that per 100 how did the Burger 100 thing come about?
Well,
I stole it from Pa Postmates to make it seem like I'm giving a hundred percent
effort to everything that I do.
I'm like p diddy without the effort.
All right.
Huddle.
Do you have eyes?
Sure.
Most of us do.
Do not the do they not work as well as they should?
Yeah.
You should see the size of the font that I'm reading here.
Do you like spending less money on things than more money on things?
Yes.
I love how easy these questions are.
The school is this easy?
I would have gone to Harvard.
Uh,
do you know what the Internet is?
Yes.
If yes,
then visit Hubble context.com
Hubb Ellie humble
context.com.
That sounds like a nickname of wife would give to her fat husband.
Oh,
it's my humble.
Uh,
talk about how when you started out in comedy,
all the other comics teased you for your coke bottle.
Glasses.
Blind Billy.
Bad eyes they call you at not at your heart,
toward your soul.
You seed with rage.
But deep down you knew they were right.
What is this copy here?
I never had.
I've never had glasses.
Must say brutal.
And Bill Burke voice at least twice per spot can be out of context.
Must not get mad at Hubble for trying to be cute.
Uh,
okay.
With humble,
you'll get a fresh pair of lenses for every single day for s for less.
What?
Fresh pair of lenses.
60 contexts for $33.
Do the math.
That's barely a dollar a day.
How often do you throw out contact lenses?
I've never been in this world.
Uh,
this is more affordable than other brands.
Go to Hubba contacts.com and get your first two weeks for free.
They can send you to an optometrist if you don't have a prescription featured in
vogue,
Gq,
tech crunch,
Mashable,
and the billboard podcasts.
So do what I bill burr,
definitely 100% did.
And Go to a hubbub context.com to get your first two first two weeks of lenses
for free.
Uh,
that's 15 pairs of lenses for free.
I've never done this.
Uh,
to summarize context.
Cheaper's good,
easy,
humble Internet C,
uh,
makes sure to select my show.
Underscore Bill Burr,
underscore at checkout.
That's humble Hubb,
Ellie,
context.com.
All right,
so I guess they have cheese
contexts.
All right.
Yet you can put in your eyes.
Um,
I actually,
I need glasses,
man.
I do.
And uh,
I'm just afraid that if I wear glasses,
it's gonna make my eyes weaker.
It's kind of like,
you know,
given into using a cane,
except it's for your eyes.
I'm trying to tough it out.
I'm 50 years old and I still don't have glasses.
You know,
I'll tell you I can't
see shit,
but I'm a good listener,
um,
of all,
man.
I'm a really good listener.
All right.
I gotta get in there and I got to go eat lunch.
Oh,
sorry.
Breakfast with the,
with the family.
Um,
I almost just said I love you guys.
I don't even know why.
Why would I say that?
This being a dad thing is really making me soft.
It's really,
it's kind of scaring me here.
All right,
let's get back on track.
Have a great weekend.
You [inaudible] and uh,
I'll check in on you on,
uh,
on Monday.
I think.
Is there an f one race this weekend?
There wasn't one this past weekend.
I think that coming back.
Oh,
I can't wait.
That last race was my favorite fucking race.
That I'd last two have been my favorite race.
And,
um,
I'm going to go out on a limb and I'm going to say a ridiculously focused,
slightly angry
Lewis Hamilton.
He's going to put on a fucking display.
That's what I'm,
that's,
that's my guess.
All right.
You want to see something cool?
Checkout Lewis Hamilton's private jet.
Oh,
ah,
I can't imagine that.
You know what I mean?
Just flying to every gig in that fucking thing.
Do you now?
Not Funny.
I would be.
How would you show up with that grin on your face that you know,
like when those,
when when the,
the dive and rescue teams find the fucking guy who drowned in the,
in the fucking those cave divers,
they was,
had that goofy smile on their face because the last thing that happens is your
body releases all that dopamine.
That's the look I would have on my face if I had a private jet.
You know,
by the way,
there is no way to fly private and make money.
There's just no way to fucking do it unless you flew there and then did it
10,000 gigs in a row before you flew back.
I don't get how people fucking do it and people go,
Oh,
you build it into the contract.
It's like fuck it.
It's going to come out of your end.
It's going to come out of your rent.
I mean,
I think if I was to fly from here to Utah,
costs like 50 grand.
It's fucking ridiculous.
That 50 it's fucking nuts.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Enjoy the music and listen to and enjoy another half hour of a Thursday
afternoon podcasts from a Thursday afternoon.
Gone by.
All look good.
Just came walking in all shirtless with their beer belly.
How you doing buddy?
Is it me or does she just keep getting better looking guys get better looking.
Can you say hi?
Can you say Mama,
can you say Dadada?
Can you say baby?
Can you say dog?
You say Kat.
Can you say car?
Can you say,
wow.
You say,
whoa.
Whoa.
She flipped in both around the keys.
Key shoes.
Now she can almost say to civil war.
Can you say wallet
is a water?
The water
that's like the same thing.
Yeah.
You got to pick like words that begin with the letter that she knows.
I'm not trying to turn him into a gold digger baby.
Say Baby.
Yeah.
Oh,
whoa.
Baby.
Laughing.
Crying.
Say crying.
How are you doing that?
Uh,
angry.
Sleeping.
All right,
that's the podcast.
God bless you.
I'll talk to you on my,
yeah,
that's right.
Check it on.
Yeah,
I'll see you on Monday.
Oh,
just
[inaudible] the book.
We get passionate the whole and not the half of the book.
Cats in the aftermath of the
been
[inaudible]
budget split.
See that?
Buy The ticket or Kipp believe that through my day through gastric
[inaudible],
Brooklyn,
New York City when they paint murals and Vicki and Kathy truck,
cause he's getting fabulous life looked pretty fucked up kid.
He wants to still 50 cents.
3 cents is Dominic can't be covered within says my presence felt my name is
quality from the eternal refreshing.
They get absolutely as shown here from misconception.
Let me meditate.
Sadie straight came to the conclusion that most of the chapters,
but wait,
let me demonstrate.
Walk in the streets.
Just like battling.
Be careful with your body.
You must know karate.
You think that goes back to him like a fit.
You're ready to be efficient every year.
Maybe you can see your name in the column.
I'll go fishing where we serve.
Plenty to read and they're talking about,
I knew either mountain and neighbors.
Mikey with the quiet was quiet.
It's like,
Hey,
what's going on?
It's still burns to Monday morning
podcast,
the July fucking 19th 2000 fucking 10 all right,
I'm going to pissed off fucking mood because I'm not funny this week.
This is the third fucking time I've started this Goddamn podcasts.
They had a race.
Two of them got 12 minutes into the first one and I just said,
fuck it,
and I erased it and this one,
I got 24 fucking minutes in and I,
I just,
I,
I just erased it and rather than walking away and walking down the Goddamn
street and clear my fucking head,
I,
I just hit stop and I hit a race and then I just start the fucking thing again
thinking like,
oh,
maybe,
maybe this will work.
Let me do a do over.
You know,
I,
do you know what it is?
I'm on the fucking road.
I went to Montreal and now I'm in New York and I just,
I want to go home.
I've had it.
I don't want to sleep in any more of these fucking hotel rooms.
I don't want to order any more fucking room service.
I'm in New York.
Are you ordered a Goddamn fucking protein salad with a fucking [inaudible]
salad?
Cause I thought they were Mozzarella,
Mozzarella sticks.
However the fuck you goddamn sons of bitches from Italy say it
fucking shows up.
So I ordered a salad and a fucking sal.
Do you know what it cost me?
It cost me fucking almost 50 bucks with the tip
because I'm staying in midtown midtown.
Therefore we can.
We can rape you.
You want some fucking advice.
If you ever come to New York,
do not stay mid tab too.
God Damn fucking,
they deliver the fucking food.
The guys weren't a Goddamn ski mask.
Fucking pantyhose over his fucking face.
It's unbelievable.
We send up there,
they always set up some fucking,
you know guy who can't even speak fucking English,
right?
So you know,
it's not his fault.
You know,
he didn't come up with the Goddamn menu.
Poor bastard.
He still has scurvy from floating over on his goddamn luggage coming up here.
Fucking dazed given me the Goddamn,
I can't fucking believe it.
You know?
And if you've never stayed in a fucking New York hotel room either,
this is how it works.
It costs $400 for the night and you're like,
wow,
this is going to be amazing though,
right?
And you open the fucking door and what happens?
You take a step and a half,
you trip over the fucking bed,
you roll over the bed like that.
Do Sean Starsky and Hutch Hutch go on right over the hood of his fucking Grand
Torino.
And rather than coming up in a cool way with your Adidas dragons on,
you do a face plant right into the fucking wall.
And if half the second you're like,
oh,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
There's a ray of light.
I actually have two side by side windows.
Let's check out the view.
And all you see is a fucking the brick building next to you.
Do you know I can't even commit suicide out of this fucking window.
That's how close the building is next to me.
Hang on a second.
Yes,
it's okay.
I'll come back later.
I'm doing the podcast.
All right,
thank you.
And like how I assume that she's a fan actually got a laugh out of her.
Um,
but she had an accent.
I just said I'm doing the podcast.
She probably thinks that some sort of new dance or that I'm fucking my wife and
it's some sort of new weird position.
I'd love to open the door,
but we're doing the podcast.
Um,
anyways,
let's get back to killing myself.
Um,
if I were to jump out this building and trying to kill him,
I wouldn't kill myself.
What would actually happen was I would slide down between both buildings
excruciatingly slow,
scraping them the fucking skin off of both as cheeks,
the back of my head,
my nose,
and the helmet of my Dick and the top of my feet.
I would have my feet pointed down like Greg Louganis,
you know,
coming out of a fucking triple Lindy going right into the Olympic pool.
How does he do it?
How does he not fucking create a Goddamn splash?
You're,
that guy doesn't get enough credit that fucking Greg Louganis,
you know,
all they talk about is how he whacked his head.
And he had his fucking,
you know,
he was HIV positive and it got on the diving board for the next Ukrainian dude
who came up there.
You know what about the fact that he could basically jump off the Eiffel Tower
and somehow against the laws of physics,
not have not have a splash.
I would put that guy up there with the fucking Wayne Gretzky's,
the Michael Jordans.
You know what?
I don't know enough about diving,
so I got to strike that.
But I,
I did see some shit this weeks with someone was saying Koby Bryant had five
fucking rings.
So if he gets one next year,
he gets number six,
then you have to say that he's on par with Jordan as far as championships.
Yes,
we can all do math.
But as far as him ever eclipsing Michael Jordan,
he never will.
And I'm gonna,
I'm gonna tell you this right now.
Not only will he never eclipse Michael Jordan,
he's not even fucking close and know what all you Laker fans that thinking,
but wait a minute,
fucker.
He's doing the same fucking moves.
Yes he is.
Yes,
he is.
Physically,
he can do what Michael Jordan can do.
Yes,
he cared.
All right,
but this is the difference.
Michael Jordan created those fucking moves.
All right?
You can find a guitarist in your fucking neighborhood who can play Voodoo child.
Does that mean they're as good as Jimi Hendrix who wrote the fucking Song,
who is 20 years ahead of his fucking any other guitarist on the planet?
Look,
as great as Stevie Ray Vaughan is,
I love that guy to death.
He can't touch.
He can't fucking touch Jimi Hendrix.
He can't.
Hendrix came up with that Shit and then fucking Stevie ray modernized it,
but it was Jimmy Shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like a pilot take.
You learns how to fly and then tries to compare himself to Orville and Wilbur
Wright.
Oh,
though they fucking flew only across the field of flying across the whole
country.
I'm 3000 miles better than the people who invented flying.
All right now Coby Bryan has the,
the I think has the athletic gifts of Michael Jordan and if you had the two of
them play each other one on one at the height of their powers,
it would be the greatest one on one game ever.
All right.
But as far as the forward thinking that the athletic genius,
Colby Bryan is not an inventor,
he isn't,
he does have the drive,
he's got all that other shit but he doesn't have the ability to take the game 20
years into the future where he has no fucking pier.
There was no arguments when Jordan played,
there was no arguments about who the best guy in the league was for the last 10
years of his career.
There was a,
you know,
early on before he established himself,
people,
you know with throwing other names in there.
But after you know,
fucking 89 there was no question who the best player was.
And by fucking 92 93 he was without a doubt the greatest basketball player of
all time.
And he still is
Colby Bryant on the other hand,
his entire career.
There's always been,
well,
what about this guy?
What about that guy you know right now is he Kobe,
Lebron James?
You know,
I still give it to Colby.
Colby is still uh,
beyond Lebron James,
but Lebron James is very close.
There was no one near Jordan.
I can't even explain it to you.
It's like when you talk to those fucking Douche bags from the baby boom
generation,
those selfish Kuntz who hang their hat on,
they stopped the Vietnam War and then became corporate douche bags.
Um,
that's a big generalization for you.
Like they always say like,
no matter how much you get into the Beatles,
you just can't wrap your head around what it was like when they put out an
album,
how far ahead they were from everybody else.
It's the same thing with Richard Pryor because what happens is as the years go
by,
everybody rips those,
those geniuses off and everybody gets caught up to where the fuck they were.
And what usually happens is if you're young,
you're watching the contemporary people and then as you go back in time you go
back 30 years,
you go all the way back to prior and you see him do the black guy,
white guy thing and so many people have ripped him off that that the genius of
what he does is,
is a little tainted.
You know what I mean?
So that's like when people look at Colby and that and they go back and they look
at Jordan,
they take for granted
what Kobe's doing now because it just seems it just like that's what basketball
is now because Jordan showed,
showed them what was possible.
You understand what the fuck I'm saying here.
I'm sure Laker fans won't fucking,
they,
they'll,
they'll argue it but they're fucking morons anyways.
They're going to be like Jordan is just as good as Jordan.
You know the same way.
They try to claim that they have fucking 16 championships or this other do.
She wrote me this week who tried to say they have 18 this such,
there's just no way to respect a Laker fan.
I just cause some,
they just transplanted fucking dis.
There's so few people from Los Angeles.
And what happens is people move out there,
you know,
Hollywood fucking phoneys and then the Lakers,
they always have some fucking amazing team there are hell of,
they're an awesome franchise.
I think they uh,
wait how many championships they got since 1980.
He won five.
Eight.
They nine.
They are better than the Yankees since 1980 better than the Canadians.
They are the franchise.
All right.
This is all these fucking assholes go out there and they see Jack Nicholas at a
fucking true fan.
Jack Nicholson.
What the fuck is wrong with me every time I want to say Jack Nicholas,
I say Nicholson and vice,
he Versie there.
God help me if they're ever in the same fucking room,
really built when the fuck would that happen.
Huh?
When you do some corporate gig for some people who actually did something with
their life and you go in there like a dancing monkey and then afterwards try to
talk to them in the green room,
is there clearly blowing you off?
Um,
um,
anyways,
the fuck am I talking about here?
Yeah.
All those Douche bag Laker fans.
You know,
I talked to one the other day like,
Oh dude,
I'm die hard.
And I found out he was from New York.
How the fuck do you go from being a Knicks fan to being a Lakers fan?
I'll tell you why.
You become a fucking phony.
How do you leave New York and moved to la?
How do he do that?
You know,
unless you're in show business,
which was he?
I think he was,
I can't remember.
I drank so much this fucking week.
All of everybody's just amalgam.
Everybody's just a big,
I'm just amalgamating,
if that's even a word,
into just one big face,
just running their goddamn miles.
My own fucking lawyer is a Laker Fan.
Okay.
And we had that argument about the 16 championships and he just would not answer
my questions.
I've got a real thrill out of it of being a lawyer in a fucking argument because
I just kept hitting him with that argument.
You know,
I go,
you go to the staples center,
all right.
Now,
you know,
first of all,
if you're going to make a 16 championship tee shirt,
because the law,
the the Laker,
the Laker franchise has 16 championships.
That is undebatable.
Okay.
But the Los Angeles Lakers have 11 the Minneapolis Lakers have five.
So when you make those 16 championship fucking tee shirts,
you gotta say Minneapolis Slash Los Angeles.
Okay.
Take the hint from the Laker franchise.
When you go to the staples center and they don't have the Minneapolis banners up
there because those banners belong to the franchise slash the fans of fucking
Minnesota in Minneapolis the same way.
And I've made this fucking goddamn example a zillion times and I'm going to keep
making it because every fucking week,
some Goddamn Laker Fan,
this is the last week I'm going to do it because now people would send me those
emails on purpose.
But like if the Lakers now move from Los Angeles to Las Vegas,
they win it next year for the franchise is 17th Championship people in Los
Angeles.
What would you do with somebody from Vegas came walking up to you?
When went that 17 bitch.
We have 17 fucking NBA championships.
We are the New York Yankees of fucking basketball.
Would that,
would that make sense to you if you
saw Las Vegas Lakers?
17 championships and they will walk around,
thrust in their chests out
the Boston Celtics have won 17 championships all in Boston.
Okay,
that's it.
And a few people in La,
you're still confused.
Like I've said before,
just think how am count,
how many times you've thrown a rock through the wind storefront window of an
athlete's foot foot.
I can't even fucking talk this week.
How many times do you burned down your city?
How many times you've burned down the La area?
That's how many championships you have.
All right?
So stop padding your fucking resume.
Like all you cons do out there,
your Goddamn Pa,
and by the time you type up your resume,
you fucking directed the movie fucking phony.
Who can't even show up to the game on time.
Um,
all right,
where are we going?
Hey,
where the fuck do we go from here?
All right,
so how much time did that take up?
How much momentum?
All right.
That was a good 14 fucking minutes.
Let me shut off this overhead light may not have fucking piece of shit.
Plastic foreign hundred bucks a night,
fucking pricks.
Um,
anyways,
I am here in New York and,
uh,
I did the Montreal comedy festival this week.
Uh,
that was a big thrill,
you know,
that's why I drank so fucking much this weekend.
I just ran into a bunch of comedians I haven't seen in a long,
long fucking time.
Um,
you know,
cause everybody I know fucking headlines now so we never get to work together
anymore.
So just we're drinking and telling stories and just laughing our fucking asses
off and I'll tell you,
it's a goddamn shame nobody filmed it because there's like nine zillion
documentaries out there trying to capture the backstage stand up fucking thing.
And uh,
I don't think they've ever done it.
And the only way you could ever do it is if you'd have to do it like a reality
show where you keep the cameras rolling
24,
seven in that way,
people gradually forget about them because that's what they have to do.
They have to forget that they're on camera.
So you actually hear the fucking stories and the,
uh,
I don't know the level you have to go to,
to make another comedian laugh.
Um,
this put it this way.
This podcast is PG 13 compared to the shit that we talk about.
So anyways,
that's what I was doing.
I was drinking booze.
I was having a great time up there.
Um,
and I'm fucking wiped out.
But,
um,
I'm actually taping this right now on the 18th.
Sunday the 18th,
and I'm doing the David Letterman program,
the late show tomorrow night.
I got my suit.
I got to get my shoes polished.
I got my fucking cufflinks,
you know,
nice fucking shirt.
And as always,
I know people are gonna send me emails.
Dude,
why did you wear as sweat?
Did you dress up
for the greatest fucking,
you know,
talk show out there,
Bill?
I don't understand it.
Everybody else on the show is dress really nicely.
Why did you go on the show and dress really nicely?
Why didn't you go out there and dress like you were headlining the funny bone in
fucking Dayton,
Ohio.
Why did you dress like you were in the Ed Sullivan Theater?
Do you guys realize you young punks that that's the fucking same stage where the
Beatles came out and broke in the United States.
And if you'll watch him,
they were wearing suits.
You're dumb fucks.
Really don't understand that you show up to a Toga party.
If you wear a suit,
you can give somebody then when in Rome cunts,
when in Rome.
Um,
so anyways,
this is going to be my fifth appearance and uh,
I'm really excited.
I got a nice tight set.
Um,
I am kind of making fun of mothers right out of the gate.
So,
uh,
as always,
you know,
there's always a bit of awkwardness before people realize that I look like a
puppet and then I'm harmless and then I just write it,
write it right through.
And uh,
and then what's going to happen is after the show,
I'm going to have the fucking euphoria that I did it and I survived it.
And then I'm going to go out and I'm going to stay out too late
and then my alarm clock is going to go off 20 minutes later and I'm going to be
in the worst fucking move ever.
I better have a window seat.
That's all I can tell you because if I get woken up,
if I get the aisle seat,
you know I hate how people wake you up on a plane.
When a stranger wakes you up,
is there anything more creepier than the touch of a stranger trying to not
disturb you from your sleep?
That little two fingered,
not quite a poke,
not quite a caress that they do into your shoulder and then they speak in like
half sentences.
They don't just,
they don't just,
you know,
you know what?
You know it'd be acceptable like a man demand,
like a back of the hand fucking on,
on the side of your leg.
As intimate as that sound.
I'll give you the sound just like this.
Hey Man,
I got to get up.
Use the bathroom.
I just like that,
but for some reason,
because you,
I don't know if it's because of nine 11,
I don't know what,
but people just,
they the two finger and then they,
and then they sort of whisper a half a sentence.
They fuck you just feel this creepy fucking pedophile touch.
It startles you.
The exact thing they don't want to do.
It's such a creepy touch.
It does startle you.
You fucking whip your head around over to them and then at some another man
whispering I half a sentence.
Yeah.
I just had,
I,
I just wanted to,
yeah.
Can I just,
can you just what you fucking asshole.
Finish the goddamn sentence and stop fucking
finger rape in me.
Whatever the hell you just did there.
That's the old shoulder finger rape at 30,000 feet.
Um,
which is actually a new phrase acceptable in the Webster's dictionary.
Can you believe that?
How many of you,
I am so sick of them fucking bringing that up on talk shows.
Do you know that chilling is now an acceptable word in the dictionary?
Well,
do you know that everybody's using it?
You fucking idiots.
That's how they become words.
You can have words that everybody is using and you're not going to put them in
the dictionary.
Why are people so fucking stuck up about that?
Ooh,
good Chilean couldn't look woo.
And like there's any class left fucking doing Vegas,
people showing up in Hawaiian shorts with flip flops and you can't put Schilling
in the God damn dictionary.
You know,
keep stopping these fucking plagues people.
And that's what you're going to have.
You're going to have a weaker species of fucking human beings.
All right?
And they're gonna use fucking slang words and eventually you're going to have to
stick them in the dictionary because you're going to want to come.
You'd be able to communicate to the people.
You always have to be able to communicate to the people because if he can't
communicate to them,
then you can't give them the fucking lie.
You can't spend your own fucking story
of why we're all scampering around down here as you sit in your fucking manner.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I've been dying to do a bit about the kind of people I think should get the
death penalty
and one of them is these fucking bankers.
I really believe,
man,
if you shake up the economy like a goddamn and farm and you make fucking old
people have to eat al Po for the last 18 years of their fucking life,
and I might just talking about five or six of them.
I'm talking about an,
you know,
a large percentage of an entire generation.
These fucking banker cunts.
Okay.
Fucked over people.
Basically the generation that won World War II,
it's unbelievable.
Then even go to jail.
They don't even fucking go to jail.
I Dunno.
I think they should give all old people fucking,
they should just give them those paintball guns and then they should just tell
them where the,
where the fucking rich people live,
the bankers and they should just go on and just see every once in a while drive
by and shoot him and they never get arrested.
That's what I think that they should do.
All right.
Once again,
just like the last two podcasts.
This thing's starting to Peter out right around 21 minutes.
52 seconds.
Can I be funny up until 22 seconds,
I got another four seconds to do it.
Three seconds.
That's not going to happen.
Jesus.
This is the longest 50 minutes ever.
Fucking goddamn George's popped out too.
I'll tell you guys then they said that I grinded my teeth at night.
Like I didn't know that I could,
didn't know that I was an absolute psycho and had angry dreams about murdering
people.
So they give me this fucking mouth guard and I put the mouth guard on it and now
my jaw just dislocates every once in awhile.
Okay.
And I so don't like paperwork and shit that I would never even consider sowing
them.
Oh my God,
this sucks.
And I've just figured out how to pop it back in again.
Right now it's out of alignment.
Let me see if,
let me try to bite down.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I feel like I had a ball side of my fucking jaw.
Any dentist out there can tell me why that happened.
I can't even,
you know,
you know why the first time it happened I came be leaving.
I'm going tell you this,
I can't tell you how,
first time I dislocated my job was,
uh,
how do I tell it in a clean way?
I don't do sex jokes,
but,
uh,
I was going down on a girl and I was trying to fucking jam my tongue in there
and I think it pushed my lower back.
She was getting really into it,
you know,
and I was younger so I didn't know how to make them come.
And she was getting close and I was so fucking exhausted.
I just went forward.
I was in the red zone.
I was like,
we got a score here.
This fucking game is over.
And then when,
you know,
I came up out of the fucking,
what the fuck do you call it?
I don't know.
The concubines.
I know somewhere with this,
see that began there and I wasn't going to say cunt.
I came up out of there,
uh,
you know what,
that laminated face and a,
yeah,
I noticed it was difficult to bite down.
And ever since then I had a problem.
I think I just ruined my lawsuit cause if they listened to the podcast,
actually he admits on the podcast on July 18th,
2010,
then it was actually jamming his tongue into a vagina in Laughlin,
Nevada.
Yeah.
There's no way to make that up.
It's fucking true.
Oh,
Jesus Christ is an aging.
Isn't it?
Just funny how things like that happen.
Um,
anyways,
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking thing to admit.
You can tell him flailing when I started to fucking admit and that shit.
24 minutes.
Here we go.
Let's plow ahead.
I was watching ESPN today and um,
and of course,
you know,
as always,
you had four really intelligent people on a panel who are all involved in a
debate that none of them knew was even remotely true,
but they engaged in it anyways because it would piss off a guy like me and make
me continue to watch.
So then I then see the commercials so they can justify their advertising so that
those four cock suckers can get paid.
I refuse to believe that Bob Ryan,
John Saunders,
though they're not dumb guys than not,
but if you listen to what they're arguing,
it's the stupidest shit ever.
Basically,
because a tiger woods hasn't won a major this year.
They're questioning whether he's ever basically going to be able to put it back
together again.
Completely ignoring the fact that he got busted for cheating almost 30 times on
his wife in front of the entire country,
and that he's going through a divorce right now that you know she wants $700
million
and he's wants to give her 300 million.
They're in the process of negotiating that and also he's got,
he's going through a period in his life where he realized that he fucked up his
whole marriage.
You know,
if you guys,
you know,
not forget,
if you've been fucked up relationship,
you haven't gone through relationship that ends and you got to go through your
fucking town and everywhere you go,
you've got a memory of that person.
You sit in there welling up in a Johnny rockets.
Would you like to get some French fries?
Yes.
Your thought she loved French fries we used to share of um,
all that shit.
So he,
you don't think he's going through that on a worldwide basis,
traveled the world with that woman and just be,
you know,
when you fuck up to that level,
you always want to go back.
You know,
you have to go through the regret before you can move on.
So I'm sure he's sitting there at the British open as much as he's trying to
block it out as much as he's a competitor,
there's no way as a human being for you not to be sitting here going,
man,
this time last year,
my life was so different,
even though I didn't win it last year when I came up on 18,
but she didn't play last year because his knee was hurt or whatever.
The last time he played it,
you know,
um,
or maybe he did,
I don't fucking know.
He was coming up 18 and his wife was sitting there with their kid and he got the
hug and on the kiss and all that type of shit.
And it's not there.
And he has to deal with that.
And this is a fucking guy that,
you know,
he's a human being.
They're such idiots.
The guy won a fucking tournament when his knee was blown out and he was
screaming in pain after every goddamn shot and he's still fucking it.
And they're going to question this guy with a reconstructed knee.
You know,
the guys in his early thirties,
they've already written him off.
Jack Nicholas won his final fucking,
uh,
master's at like 45,
46 years of age.
It's this,
it's,
the whole debate was so fucking beneath guys like Bob Ryan,
John Saunders,
who was that?
Who the guy was.
It was,
if you just sit there going,
you guys don't even believe this shit.
You just trying to cause controversy because you have to fill up 24 fucking
hours.
And that right there is why I don't watch those shows,
you know?
But you know,
unless I'm on the fucking road and I've got nothing else to do and then I
completely fucking pisses me off.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
here's a question I got this week,
um,
from a listener.
Um,
Bill,
I have a question.
I had been dating a Filipina girl who is too short to be seen with in public.
Geez.
I mean,
what,
what a what a way to start the story.
I'm seeing a girl who I can't be seen with in public.
Okay.
This relationship has legs.
Um,
and the fact that I'm six foot three doesn't help at all.
I mean,
she is really small for foot five.
This is one of the great sentences I've ever read.
Listen to this.
Technically she's a midget.
So you would think people would kind of leave us alone out of respect for her
shortness.
Sir.
Do you realize that really short people or little people want to be called
little people?
They Fund midget is offensive.
I learned that.
I didn't think it was,
I actually have that on my CD going.
It was never a racial slur.
You know,
midgets weren't dragged here from another country and forced to do labor.
You're a midget.
What's wrong with that?
And evidently a PT Barnum came up with it or something just to let you know,
cause I didn't know midget was offensive either or I knew it was offensive,
but I didn't understand why.
Uh,
Mitch is like the name for a really tiny bug I guess.
So that's what they were saying.
They say when you like you were like is small as a little,
but they were comparing it to a little fucking insect,
you know?
And that goes to the elephant man think I am not an insect.
I am a human being.
What's the do with mood shifts?
Um,
so technically she's a midget.
So you would think people would kind of leave us alone out of respect for her
shortness.
But people's people stare me down everywhere we go.
She's cute,
nice and sweet,
but I feel uncomfortable being part of a side show all the time.
Do you think it's acceptable for a tall man to date a tiny,
a tiny women,
tiny woman is what you mean?
Do I think it's acceptable.
Yeah,
it's totally acceptable.
Date with who you want to a date.
What's not,
what's not acceptable is dating someone you're not comfortable being seen with
in public?
Um,
I would work on not giving a fuck or I would get out of the relationship because
,
uh,
I don't know how she hasn't picked up on it already,
but,
uh,
if you're not comfortable with the person you're dating,
I mean,
I don't know if someone can walk down the street with me and be comfortable
walking down the street with a fucking red headed freak.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
you know,
you could get comfortable with her
and when you,
when you walked down the street with it,
you don't have her like fucking,
you know,
one of those,
you don't have a one of those kiddie things,
you know,
where she's sitting on you that your chest like a fucking primate.
I guess we're all primates,
aren't we?
You know,
in monkeys when the fucking monkey just hangs on the other,
you know,
wraps her arms around your back.
Yeah,
I'm being a Dick Right now.
You ever in a fanny pack?
See this,
I'm doing the exact fucking thing.
Well,
you got to understand that's what people are going to do.
You've got to understand if you're a different looking,
couple people are going to give you shit and you just got to get beyond it.
You know,
that's all I can say.
I shouldn't have made those jokes.
Cause now you're probably thinking like,
see,
you're being a con too.
I'm not being a content being a guy who is not even remotely funny.
This fucker we trying to trudge through 15 fucking minutes,
50 minutes of a podcast.
All right?
So I have to make fun of everything.
So,
uh,
I dunno.
She's adorable.
She's nice.
If you think she's the one I would,
I would stay with her.
Um,
if you don't think she's the one,
get out of it immediately because even if she's not the one,
eventually you'll have feelings for,
and then when you break up with her,
you know,
when you sat her on the coffee table and say,
look,
we have to have a talk.
I'm sorry dude,
I'm on any joke.
Any,
any port.
In a storm.
I got to fucking do it and she starts crying.
You know,
it's the worst.
That's why you know something.
I'll tell you right now.
This is why like I love how it's unacceptable to break up with somebody over the
phone.
You know who came up with that is women because they know how guilty they can
make us fucking feel when they start crying.
They want to make us feel is bad.
It's a total vindictive fucking mood.
There's nothing wrong with breaking up with somebody on the phone.
There's nothing wrong with like that dude on sex in the city who wrote it on a
post it and stuck it to the TV.
I have a girlfriend,
I have seen some episodes of that show.
Um,
although I never get to the whole one because I would always piss my girl off
cause anytime the hoary girl would make us anything she said in the show was
always sexually related.
And I told you guys this before and any lines she said after she said it,
I would just go cause she's a whore and it would just piss my girl off to no one
until by the end of the show.
She was doing it too.
But anyways,
I digressed.
Let's fucking,
let's fucking just plow ahead.
There's nothing wrong
no matter what.
It's going to make them cry.
There's nothing wrong with breakups with someone through email.
There's nothing wrong with doing it with the post it.
There's nothing wrong with doing it over the phone in a way.
There's actually,
it's a caring thing that they're doing.
It's like,
I care about you so much and it would hurt me so much to see how much I'm
hurting you that I can't even deal with watching how much I'm going to hurt you.
You know,
and you're out.
It's a vindictive thing that women want you eyeball to eyeball watch you stand
there and watch.
You crushed them by saying,
I don't want to be in a fucking relationship with you anymore.
You know,
it's fucking awful.
What I always do.
And you know,
back in the day when I used to have to break up with somebody,
I used to just think this.
All right,
dude,
it's,
it's two hours of your life.
The first leg of it.
It's like the Tour de France.
Okay.
We're just trying to get to the mountains.
All right?
The first two hour fucking leg.
She's going to cry.
It's gonna suck.
We have to stick to your fucking guns.
All right?
Sit down.
Just say in this,
probably people out there right now who need to get out of a relationship and
you just don't know how to do it cause you're young.
All right?
It's not going to get better.
You can't make yourself love the person.
You just have to fucking get out of it.
And this goes for the broads out there too.
He just have to go,
look,
we need to talk.
All right?
I don't know what's going on,
but I'm just not happy anymore,
you know,
and you can use all the hacky stuff.
You're a great person,
but I'm just not,
I'm not feeling it.
I'm just not.
And
you know,
that's celebrities to it.
Look,
I'm already getting nervous.
His picture in the girl cry crying.
It's all there.
You know,
you're,
it's not fair to you.
It's not fair to you.
It's
so,
what do you say?
We care at work and this is the thing they tried to fucking,
they try to save it and you just have to be like that dude in the first star
wars.
Stay on target.
Right.
Woo.
Well,
you know,
I've,
I've been thinking things like that too.
I just think we don't see each other enough big,
you know,
and maybe that's what I've been avoiding.
You,
you can't say that can't be mean and just be like,
look,
no.
Um,
um,
is truly how I feel.
And
yeah,
that's,
it's just,
it's just how I feel.
And then just let them emote and let them go.
You know,
it's like deep sea fishing.
When you get that line,
you seen the fucking thing takes off.
We got fight.
You gotta let it go.
You can't fucking clamp the thing down and then snap the line.
You know,
zen,
she's free.
She's going to come back around and attack the fucking boat,
like in jars.
You got to let it go,
jump up out of the water,
flop around and get fucking tired,
you know,
and,
and uh,
yeah,
and you just,
you just,
it's a two hour fucking thing.
Okay.
And all you have to do is just say,
are you failing?
And then just let her fucking run and start fucking crying
and go through all the emotions she needs to,
to,
to get through.
And you just have to sit there and stick to your guns.
All right.
And then comes the hardest part
is,
uh,
if you're in her apartment,
that's a great thing.
So you can fucking leave.
It's worse if you do it in your apartment because then you have to kick them
out.
So yeah,
that's how I feel.
And uh,
I need you to vacate the premises and readies as you say that you got to have
your friends step out dressed like a bouncer with one of those fucking cell ear
ear piece things.
Okay.
Standing there like a bouncy you when they stand with their hands folded in
front of him one hand holding the wrist of the other arm,
you know,
now you got to do it over to her place and just say,
yeah,
okay,
I'm not going to date anybody for a while or whatever the fuck you got to say.
And I,
I just,
you know,
and if she says,
can I call you?
You just,
yeah,
you just say yes,
yes you can.
And then decide whether you really meant that or not later,
but uh,
okay.
Yeah,
and I dunno.
And then you got,
I don't know,
then you get,
you got to get,
and then you've got to get away from him.
You got to get away from him.
Um,
because if you keep coming back,
it just starts the pain over again.
And then also,
yeah,
on your level is you're going to have to try to get over them even though you
are over him,
but still now you're going to be alone.
You can have that panic attack.
Well,
who am I going to be with?
What did I use to do when I was single?
How did I fill up all this fucking time?
Just ride it out.
Just know it's going to suck for six weeks.
All right.
Six weeks later you're out.
Football season starts,
you know the smell of fall comes through the fucking windows.
Yeah.
You know?
Buddy fucking brings over maybe a couple of girls who were into sports.
You find another one.
Got To have a look at her.
Okay.
And then you're on your,
on your fucking way.
It's spring again in the fall.
See it as a happy ending.
That's how you fucking do it.
Jesus Christ.
There was some advice for you how to fucking break up with somebody.
Do you guys have any stories about like the worst way you were ever broken up
with or the best,
best way somebody ever broke up with you?
You know,
I broke up with someone one time and then I bought her a hotdog
and it was weird.
It was when I was a little bit older and I just had a really,
it was just totally fucking honest.
I just had an honest talk and I said,
look,
we're both,
we're both couple psychos.
I mean,
haven't you noticed?
I had you ever have that fucking relationship where everything,
it just doesn't feel right and then you freak out,
you have an argument and then you've just fuck,
okay.
And then it feels right again.
And then it slowly starts going off course again,
and then you have a big argument and then you fuck again right after it.
Yeah,
I dunno,
I just finally hit me.
I was just like,
yeah,
well this is just,
this relationship isn't working okay,
really isn't working.
And then what happens is,
is then we fuck,
and it's a lot of fun.
It's just,
it's just based on sex.
We're having a really good time fucking before indicating,
okay,
if I could try to be a gentleman here,
that's basically what we're doing.
But other than that,
we don't really enjoy each other's company.
You want a hot dog?
You know what it was was I did it early enough in the relationship where the
woman's still actually respected me and she actually complimented me.
I mean,
it was a little more involved than that.
MMM.
But she actually called me.
She goes,
you know what?
That was a,
that was a pretty good breakup.
I gotta give it to you and then you walked me down to the train.
We wave goodbye as the train slowly went away.
It's like the end of like a fucking a film noir movie.
What else?
Classic films.
He played it for her.
You can play it for me.
Play it for me.
They're fucking black guy who doesn't get any lines cause it's the 1940s math.
I um,
I was actually the TV here in my walk in closet.
$400 a night fucking hotel.
Um,
I was actually watching that Turner movie classics,
man.
Jesus Christ.
When I get on that thing,
forget about it.
I was actually,
I watched,
you know,
like the road movie,
the Buddy road movie.
I didn't realize this.
The first is the guys who invented that genre of movie,
um,
was um,
what was it?
Bing Crosby and fucking Bob hope.
I had no idea.
And they will write as I had to go out last night to watch,
um,
to go run my set.
They had the third in their trilogy and I forget of the buddy movies.
I think they did more after that,
but I guess this was their best one.
And I can't remember the name of the movie,
but the,
basically
the premise of the movie was that they went to some fucking Arabian,
you know,
back then there was no Middle East.
Everything was just Arabian,
whatever the fuck that meant.
Or does that mean like Arabic country?
I don't fucking know.
But the whole thing was they had to get out of something.
So Bing Crosby cells,
uh,
Bob Hope into slavery.
Like slavery was still funny back then.
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
All I know is I watched the thing and bright,
the movie that I watched right before that was a movie called zero hour and it
absolutely blew me away.
I'm sitting there watching this movie.
I came in and the middle of this,
this flick and there's a guy talking about this guy who's got to try to land
this plane and the guy's name is Ted striker.
I'm going Ted striker.
That was the name of the guy in airplane and it's literally the same movie.
And I finally fucking realize that that was the movie that airplane was Paris
making a parody of,
um,
was a movie called zero hour that came out in like the mid fifties for the life
of me.
I thought that they will make fun of,
you know,
those movie airport airports,
76 airports,
77,
those ones with like George Kennedy,
I thought that they were making fun of those movies and they weren't,
they basically almost did a frame for frame remake of zero hour.
And um,
if you don't want to watch the movie,
go on Youtube and watch airplane versus zero hour,
you can't fucking believe
how similar.
I mean all these subtle things.
They brings the kid up to the cockpit.
A Billy ever been up in a cockpit before and he's like,
no,
this is my first time except in the real one.
The first one it drops off there but an airplane.
Then the guy says,
Billy,
you ever seen a grown man naked?
They added all that shit.
So zero hour,
check out that movie.
I'll give you the youtube videos for the week of my,
at least at 30 minutes,
44 minutes.
I somehow fucking did it again this week.
All right.
Youtube videos of the week.
Go check out a best have balls of steel to jackass show from,
I dunno,
over in England and uh,
these guys are fucking great.
They're fucking,
they're just hilarious.
And they keep going to this.
Mcdonald's gave me four big macs.
Gimme seven double cheeseburgers and some fucking daddy down.
It's,
I don't know a ditty donuts are,
but they just keep going in some fucking daddy down.
It's,
and it makes me laugh every time and I just butchered it.
I'm telling you,
it's funny.
And also for you animal fans out there.
Watch Eagle verse goat,
I guess in the wild.
This is how strong these eagles are.
They find little goats and they fly down to them that goes,
Eh,
fucking runaway.
The Eagles,
grab them,
pick them up,
just we'll grab one of their legs and they drag him off the cliff and just drop
them.
That's how they kill him.
But they actually have the ability to fly a little bit with them.
That's how strong they are.
And they wait til they're high enough and then they just drop them and they
bounce down off the cliff,
like some sort of x Gamer who lost his footing and uh,
the goat dies and then they fly down,
they fucking eat it.
And there you go.
And I think that that's going to be the podcast for this week.
Cause I,
uh,
I actually have to go a,
it's New York.
I got to go do some shit.
You know,
people don't go to New York,
just stay in the hotel rooms.
That's how we justify making them so fucking small
goddamn cons.
Hey,
let me,
uh,
let me hype some of the Shit that I actually have coming up.
Um,
here's something that actually fell out of the sky.
I have a gig coming up in Chicago.
All right,
and why isn't my fucking webpage loading official site of Bill Burr,
Bill,
burr.com,
everybody,
it'll you a better person.
Um,
my next gig after I do Letterman is on a Friday of this week,
July 23rd,
um,
uh,
I'm working with Vince Vaughn and Kevin James.
It's part of that Vince Vaughn wild west tour.
We're doing the park West Theater in Chicago,
Illinois.
I have the link right on my website.
Um,
I'm just going to be doing like 15 minutes,
but it's going to be me,
Vince Vaughn,
Kevin James,
and uh,
I forget who else,
but it's like just a ridiculously star studded shoe and she definitely check it
out and bring your friends,
bring everybody you fucking can.
All the proceeds from,
uh,
from this show will go to,
the people who worked on the show,
the performers,
all the proceeds will actually go to the periphery,
and we'll go out and buy shiny shit with it.
So,
just want to thank all you guys ahead of time.
After that,
on July 31st I'll be at the shoreline amphitheater in mountain view,
California with like 10 other fucking comedians doing something up there for a
radio program.
And a,
my next solo show though,
is going to be at the comedy store in La Jolla,
California,
which is,
uh,
just north of San Diego.
So all you guys down in San Diego who have always asked me when the fuck you
coming.
I'm coming on August 6th and August 7th.
All right.
In the last thing will be,
I'm going to hype,
I'm Newport Yachting Center in Newport,
Rhode Island,
August 12th and the Hampton Beach Casino in Hampton,
New Hampshire,
Hampton Beach,
New Hampshire on August 13th.
And I'm,
by the way,
last week I did a little rant,
you know about the Lebron James,
you know,
being afraid of the big um,
big stage in New York and actually went down to the comedy store and uh,
ah fuck.
I always forget the pipe.
Th Th th th damn page.
The EMM podcast.com.
All right.
The MM podcast.com.
Go to that.
That's the official,
there's no other fan page for the Monday morning podcast,
the EMM,
podcast.com.
All the references I've made.
I know I made a reference to something fucking old a number of times in this
podcast.
He puts up all the references,
all the youtube videos will be there so you can just click on them as I'm
talking about him.
And um,
anyways,
we actually filmed,
I did a different rant along the same lines and they put it up on Barstool
sports.
It got a ton of fucking hits and
touch her and,
and Dave,
is that the name of the show?
I'm such a Douche.
I how did they fuck that up?
I just pan.
You don't want what it is cause I don't know how to read that.
Actually thought touch her was to share is I was like,
is it too sure the guys on BCN touch or enrich?
There we go.
My brain isn't fucking awake.
I didn't even have to look it up just for the fucking record when an APP,
you know what?
I just tried to thank those guys and I fucked up the name of this show.
Touch your enrich,
played it and then actually let me call in and hope and hype my show.
So I'm feeling like I'm really becoming Internet savvy because back in the day
I'd have to get on a plane for six fucking hours,
land,
get up two hours later,
go into their studio,
half asleep and half is funny as I usually am and try to hype my gigs.
I actually got a plug out a month beforehand or three weeks before,
two weeks.
I Dunno what the day is.
Touch her enrich.
Sorry about that guys.
What an asshole.
Um,
anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
And,
um,
I wanted to know was it easier to download last week when I put it through
garage band because I was actually able to make it a smaller audio file that it
download quicker cause I think I'm going to try and do it again this week
because I know it uploaded a lot quicker.
Was that interesting?
You know what,
I think that's very fitting that I said something that wasn't funny to end this
podcast because that's how it's felt.
I know I came out with a head of steam,
you know what I mean?
I came out guns a blazing,
Kinda like a Peyton manning football season.
Just lighten everybody up and then right in the end when it really counts,
I shit the bed.
Wow.
Did I really have to trash him?
I think I did.
All right.
You guys have a great week and a,
if you're in the Chicago area,
please come out to the show.
Um,
and that is it.
Have a great week.
All
right.
[inaudible] to shift somebody in the wings to force you to click.
And some random [inaudible] said to me,
the entity within the industry,
without a history of fit into your picture,
me living my life,
expressing my liberty,
you gotta be done properly.
My name is in the middle of the quality.
People follow me and number Cassie here,
flow and assume I'm the real one with the liver.
It's like I'm sick.